[Music]
parcel towards humans
sounds like a challenge it is man versus
beast tonight on CBS for Superbowl
greatest commercials hosted by Boomer
Esiason and NCIS LA star daniela ruah
and speaking of Super Bowl commercials
if you don't have a team in the game
this may be the only reason to tune in
right yeah him it's the Superbowl of
commercials in some say that's the best
part
meanwhile Tom Brady is hoping to get
that sixth Super Bowl ring but yesterday
he had to address controversial remarks
made about his daughter on a Boston
radio show the trouble started when
reporter Alex reamer slammed Tom's
daughter on the air over this moment on
Tom's Facebook documentary series Tom
versus time at his press conference
Brady gave the reporter a break I'd
certainly hope the guy's not fired
that's I would I would hate for that to
happen
tom is joked with Michele that Vivian
can be a handful you cannot say no to
anything you know she just yeah whatever
she tells her dad that's what I do the
series gives fans a rare look inside his
multi-million dollar mansion in suburban
Boston but when it comes to who's richer
the supermodel tops her husband
Giselle's net worth is estimated to be
360 million dollars double Tom's at 180
million the Brady Bunch intz clans
compound is massive it features a barn
and the backyard is so big Tom trains
there tom is also dad to son Jack from
his past relationship with actress
Bridget Moynahan but like everybody else
when tom needs some alone time he has a
plan you have peace and quiet with three
kids the farthest Park Place away in the
house and then I lock the doors well
that works when you live in a mansion
it's tough in a regular house
[Music]